The Joe Rogan Experience I remember the
first conversation we had
um
I guess I was like 20 ever really yeah
how old because this reminds me of it
Newton South okay cafeteria
I'm 55 55 too I'm 55. okay so we must
have both been around 20. you when you
started comedy you were 21 yeah all
right so I must have been the same age
but uh we talked about fight because I
found out you were Taekwondo guy or
something
is that what you'd fight yeah
and I asked you about fights like I said
do you have skills for fighting in real
life
and you said well it's just some things
you know that are you put you know they
put you away at Advantage with people
that aren't Fighters like you don't wait
for the fight to start you told me like
you told me you were in a cafeteria once
in South and some some kid came up and
you know people think they're gonna get
to do a preamble they think that there's
going to be a whole hey [__] you and now
we're gonna they think there's going to
be like yeah and as soon as you knew he
was there to uh threaten you you just
punched him in the sternum and he just
went down
he's like hey man
and then he just anyway so that was the
first time you'd explain that to me yeah
that could have been avoided I thought
about that one for a lot afterwards yeah
yeah
you think you'd jump the gun sometimes
you jump the gun because like they're
with great power comes great
responsibility you know the guy he
didn't know chance he was just bowing up
right it was just a knucklehead yeah you
should probably let him slide
you know that's funny yeah yeah I think
that's how you've changed too because
you were really wired then you were
tightly wired well we're talking then
about like me being 15 or 16. that's
right yeah it was and a trained fighter
at a young age
and I was also like you got this thing
you want to try out so you got a fast
car you want to hit the gas yeah of
course so let's let's see what happens
of course oh this guy yeah because
people you know in high school you're
kind of trying out bowing up on people
right you know
it's a pretty pretty nuanced thing to
ask a kid that age to know like how to
back how to back off I don't need I
don't need to fight you yeah no it's
hard it's hard for kids I just watched
this horrible brawl today uh that
someone had put up on Twitter
in a high school it was terrible where
like all these kids were fighting in the
hallway and teachers were trying to
separate it and this one kid threw this
kid to the ground and punched him
unconscious and the kid went into a
seizure and like oh God
and it's awful and a lot of it is people
that just don't know how to fight and
they don't know how to defend themselves
and then they're [__] flailing wildly
at each other and this one guy knew
something and he threw this guy to the
ground and punched him out
school's so dangerous it's so dangerous
because kids are just starting to get
testosterone they're just starting to
become like strong and like a like
almost a man and out of lopsided too
these other kids who didn't it just
didn't kick in yet yeah yeah well these
kids were it was all there was none of
that they were similar sized but it was
just awful it's just awful there's also
weird energy in school for kids that age
that's
intricate like I remember I saw a lot in
my high school fights that were between
friends
because there's always somebody who
wants people to fight so it's somebody
who doesn't fight but wants a fight to
happen everybody wants to see it so you
take a a kid who's trying to get some
kind of status with a certain group and
they go why are you friends with that
guy you know like that guy's a [__] and
they actually turn him on his they want
to see if they can make a kid fight a
friend to his I saw that so many times
yeah and I saw a lot of kids that were
tough and but had a head you know smart
kids who were I remember this one kid
his name was Chris and his friend Doug
was pushed into like he's I'm gonna kick
your ass and Chris could have beat Doug
but he just started crying because
it was too much yeah pressure and he
didn't want to fight his friend and he
could hurt his friend real bad
and he's isolate everybody's around him
he's like now the kid the [__] you know
and he just started crying and then
everybody starts laughing at him because
he's crying and now he's mad
and he just beat Doug's face
it's like he painted his face right oh
no why don't humiliating fights I ever
got into was I there's never even a
punch Throne it was me I was 14 and
there's this kid in the locker room and
I don't remember the what words were
said but we were standing in front of
each other
and uh this is before I even was really
into martial arts this is one of the
reasons I got into it this kid grabbed
me in a headlock threw me on the ground
and was gonna punch me in the face
but then stopped and decided not to so I
was gonna let you up and I was like
so humiliated
it would have been better if he hit you
because then you look a little bit tough
for taking the punch well at least I
mean he was so unconcerned that I could
do something to him that he just let me
up and then I like would avoid him like
in school like if I would like look down
the hallway yeah and like I would open
up the door to the outside Breezeway and
I saw him on the other side I'm like I
gotta go around this way I got to keep
away from that guy I was terrified of
horrible terrified of him there was a
full year when I was a senior
I never really got in fights I just
didn't it just didn't happen to me I was
kind of bigger than a lot of kids my age
so I guess that you know I just didn't
and I didn't have a lot of conflicts
with people so I never really got much
into fights I just sort of slid through
you know and then it's senior year I I
don't remember junior or whatever but I
was high a lot and I was in the library
and I was laughing I was making a lot of
Racket in the library I used to get
yelled at all the time for being loud in
the library and uh this kid who's a
sophomore little kid who was like this
on me
were kind of skinny and wearing a
leather jacket he goes hey shut the [__]
up
he was just annoyed
and the worst part is he was right like
I knew in my head I'm being annoying
yeah but I said [__] you like and I'm
just like a status I'm a senior you're a
sophomore [__] you shut up and he goes
what [__] me and I go yeah [__] you and
he comes over he goes you want to go
right now I'll [__] kick the [__] out
he's smaller than me but he's wiry and
I'm like I'm scared I was terrified
because I don't want to fight this kid
even if I win I'm not gonna like go
unscathed I don't want to get hurt yeah
I don't want to be punched in the face I
don't want I don't want any of this to
happen and he's standing above me and
he's like you want to [__] go and I
was just like no I don't wanna
I don't want to fight and he's like then
shut the [__] up then and I was like and
my friends were so ashamed of me and for
the rest of the year I was terrified of
this little this little kid scared I did
an episode about it in my show and uh
where the some high school kid threatens
to beat me up and I back oh I back down
and I apologize to him oh because uh I
don't want to get yeah I that kid really
uh he'd haunted me for a long time it
can happen yeah it can happen yeah and
he's somewhere now you know I got beat
up on a bus by a girl when I was 14
because I didn't fight back I didn't
know what to do I wasn't sure if I
should hit her back yeah um when I lived
in uh Newton in Newton South we would go
to I think it was round Meadow which was
the um the middle school I think that's
what it was okay and we would walk
across the field because my sister was
going to the middle school and I was in
uh ninth grade and she was in eighth
grade so I would go and take the bus
with her because like the bus was
earlier or something I forget what it
was okay so I went over and something
happened when I got on the bus and there
was this girl who like was this tough
girl Smoked Cigarettes she had a leather
jacket that's a Newton yes and I don't
remember what happened I don't remember
what the the conversation was but she
either decided I was in the wrong seat
or whatever so she just starts wailing
on me like it wasn't even
it wasn't even like I didn't argue back
it was just like she just started
punching me yeah and then this little
guy who was like want to be my friend
his name is Mugsy Malone he wound up
being uh he later went on I think he was
a politician yeah at one point in time
but he became my friend yeah but he was
this tiny little guy he was like in
fifth grade yeah and uh and like the
girl beats me up and and then and then
he comes over he goes I ain't [__]
afraid of you either I'm like oh Jesus
it's like what the [__] is he jumped on
her side against you 100 yeah it was
like one of those things where I was
like my God I gotta learn how to fight
it's like really what turned me into a
martial artist was like tired of being
terrified this girl kicked my ass and I
didn't even fight back I was just like
covering my head up and she's just
terrible with a leather jacket on her
[__] cigarette
what is her life that she needed to go
right to Defcon five well she wound up
being the girlfriend of the guy who's
the toughest guy on the wrestling team
which I joined the next season so thank
God I didn't swing back yeah
this guy Mark Collins who was uh like
the the neighborhood tough guy he wasn't
even a small guy I wasn't even a big guy
brother he was a small guy but he was
just [__] intense and he's a really
good wrestler yeah I lived in
Newtonville which was like right along
the highway and right next to nonantum
which was all those Irish and Italian
kids and so that's who I went to Junior
High School with and mostly high school
but there was a lot of really terrifying
kids there's a lot of scary kids well
Blue Collar communities like I was in
Upper Falls yeah number Falls there was
a lot of [__] a lot of drinking yeah
everybody would hang out by Echo Bridge
yeah sure that's where my house was my
house was right next to Echo Bridge yeah
Newton had a lot of like cabbit I went
to Cabot School Elementary School in
Cabot Park was a hang and to cross Cabot
Park sometimes you'd get these guys that
would just Converge on you and they
would play games with you and you didn't
know what was going on right hey kid
come here come in then all of a sudden
you're in the middle of the park and
you're like [__] yeah I remember once as
kids he said he he had a hundred dollar
bill for some reason and he said we're
gonna play this game and they're all
surrounding me and he puts the 100 bill
on my on my hand and he gives me a
cigarette and he says if you can burn a
hole in his head all the way through
I'll give you the hundred dollar bill
I'm like I was like I don't I don't want
to do it now Jesus Christ not try it try
it and I was trying to do it and it hurt
like [__]
and I don't remember how that ended like
I just remember that terrifying and
they're all staring at me at one time
some kids had a a cup of puke it was
like a coffee cup with puke and he said
can you drink this whole thing if you
drink this whole thing we'll give you a
beer that was that thing oh God yeah
these guys I'll give you a beer yeah
these guys just scared me and then when
I grew up I hung out with those kids and
smoked cigarettes that's where I learned
to smoke cigarettes in that Park and I
drank my first beer in that Park
uh but there was kids there was a kid
named Mike who was the toughest kid in
Newton he was just a [__] terrifying
person
and there was one point where okay this
kid named David Russell he was his
family lived in Boston I don't know if
you guys had metco kids the kids that
were bussed from Boston into our schools
black kids from all black kids from
Boston who were bused into our school
system it wasn't part of that bus
bossing Boston thing it was out to the
suburbs right and these were kids that
got up at four o'clock in the morning to
go to school you know they were living a
particular life and coming out to this
suburb and some of them were my friends
one of them was Ronnie Devoe of Bell Biv
DeVoe no Chef yeah I went to high school
with him wow and uh I knew him since
like Junior High School through high
school was a nice kid and when he was in
the first edition or new New Edition
they used to come get him in a limousine
and people would say shout racist [__]
at the Bobby Brown all these guys would
be in the scene in high school was so
racist it was so crazy yes whoa so David
Russell was a Medco kid and his family's
house burnt down
in Boston and a family in Newton
actually friends of mine they had a
rental unit and they let the Russells
live there so it was like there's a
black family living in Newtonville it's
a big deal and everyone was into because
it was all liberal teachers everybody
was into like we're hosting this family
because they lost their home so all of a
sudden David Russell's living in Newton
he's not just going to school there and
one day
um Mike and his group
confront David Russell at the park and
they go Hey listen we we're really happy
you're here we want to show you this
bench right here this is your bench and
they had literally painted it black
and they painted one of the swings black
that said this is the Russell swing this
is the Russell bench you can use it many
time you want
whoa and I remember I heard that story
and I went to the park that day and it
was a black bench and a black swing and
they were there I mean I remember I went
back when I was in my 20s and it was
still a little kind of black yeah wow
yeah it was Newton Massachusetts that's
crazy